欸，你知道嗎？最近有一家小公司，做了一件你可能沒想到的事情。他們買了一座快要掛掉的地熱發電廠，然後讓它起死回生了。
買一座快掛掉的發電廠？等等，這裡我有疑問。一般公司會去買這種「燙手山芋」嗎？這聽起來就像去收購一間瀕臨倒閉的老店，風險很大吧？
對啊，這就是出乎意料的地方。這座發電廠在美國新墨西哥州，叫 Lightning Dock，是 Zanskar 這家公司在 2024 年 6 月買下來的。當時地底出來的水溫越來越低，低到根本不划算運作。
水溫越來越低？這對地熱發電廠來說，簡直是判了死刑。原本設計的運轉溫度跟實際水溫差多少？會不會是當初設計就有問題？
原文有提到具體數字。這座廠 2013 年上線，設計的運轉溫度至少要 310°F。但 Zanskar 買的時候，水溫只剩下 250°F。短短五年內，溫度下降了 50°F，等於每年掉 10°F。這速度其實很快。
哇，五年掉 50°F，這衰退速度確實很驚人。那 Zanskar 是怎麼讓它「起死回生」的？總不可能變出熱水來吧？
他們沒有變出熱水，而是用了新技術。Zanskar 的共同創辦人兼技術長 Joel Edwards 說，他們用先進的建模技術去「看」地底下的情況。結果發現，舊的兩個生產井其實只打到儲層的「頂部」，深度只有 2,500 英尺，而且位置也不理想。
所以問題是出在「打井不夠深、位置不對」？那他們做了什麼？就是重新打了一口更深的井嗎？這樣就能恢復滿載運轉？
沒錯，就是這個。他們的模型預測，如果能在新的地方打一口更深的井，電廠就能有效運轉。他們真的這樣做了，新井打到 8,000 英尺深，而且在 2025 年 5 月就開始運作了。
8,000 英尺，那比舊的深了三倍多。這樣成本會不會很高？還有，效果到底能不能持久，我覺得還有待觀察。畢竟地底狀況很複雜。
截至目前為止，新井運作了一年，每分鐘的流量還是超過 4,000 加侖。Joel Edwards 也說，電廠已經「徹底翻身了」。更厲害的是，過去一年，這座廠發出的電量，是舊井運作時的兩倍以上。
兩倍以上！那這樣成本應該是划算的。不過這點很有意思，傳統上會覺得越深越熱，但通常岩石會越緊密，水流可能就不順暢。他們怎麼解決這個問題？
其實這也是他們發現的突破點。他們發現，在新井打到的那個區域，水流實際上是增加了，而不是減少。Zanskar 的聯邦事務主管 Ben Brenner 就說，這根本改變了大家對所有地熱資產潛力的看法。
這等於是發現了一個新的模式。那如果我是創業者或公司主管，可以從這裡學到什麼？感覺這種高科技的東西，跟我們一般經營小店或公司差距有點大。
我覺得，最關鍵的是「重新評估」和「技術應用」。很多老舊的資產，就像這座地熱廠，表面上看已經沒用了，但透過新技術和不同的視角，可能還有隱藏的價值。就像有些老店生意不好，會不會是行銷方式、產品定位，其實還有很大的改善空間？
嗯，你這樣說我就懂了。就像很多傳統產業的設備，用了幾十年可能效率不高，大家想的是直接汰換。但會不會其實某些部分，透過升級或調整，也能爆發出新潛力？這模式好像不只是淘汰舊的，而是去發掘舊資產的深層價值。
對，而且 Joel Edwards 也說了，地熱界有很多「唾手可得的果實」，只是需要「再次審視」。這對我們一般上班族也很有啟發，像是手邊一些看似重複、沒效率的工作流程，會不會其實用點新工具、新方法，就能大幅提升效率？
聽起來就像，不要輕易放棄那些看似沒救、沒有價值的東西，而是要多問一句「還能怎麼辦？」「有沒有新的方法可以試試看？」然後付諸行動。
是啊，這可能就是 Zanskar 能讓一座失敗的發電廠，重新發光發熱的秘訣。好像也提醒了我們，很多時候，限制我們的不是資源本身，而是我們看待問題的角度。